Cyril votre absence sur les souffert
beaucoup souffert d'autant que je n'ai
pas remarqué tout de suite à cause des
petits je peux ouvert tranquille
tranquille depuis
impossible de m'endormir sans penser à
merveille obligé de compter divorce
enfants cachés et pour trouver le
sommeil sans vous j'ai eu l'impression
de perdre un frère Cyril
ça marchera toujours par terre
[Rires]
c'est pas là mais tu
viens après dire quelle année
je suis pas douée pour les discours et
je sais votre amour pour la littérature
et je sais que vous avez un livre de
chevet qui est également le mien et je
savais que ça allait vous vous parlez il
s'agit des Méditations poétiques de
Lamartine
[Rires]
[Musique]
je n'attends rien du jour le ciel
s'assombrit le nuage de chez un seul
être vous manque et tout est dépeuplé
[Applaudissements]
pour que
la poire
j'espère que ça vous tous je
pense que c'est de la merde merci c'est
de la merde
Alexandra Alexandrie Alexandra
non c'est Siri c'est pas Siri
vous êtes belle comme une hirondelle
Lebel
votre profil grec me donne envie de
manger un kebab
qui annonce notre portefeuille rempli
[Rires]
stress je vous embrasse Kelly
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier avec ça tu nous admirions des
tableaux et comme nous avons vu les
coquelicots de Monet nous l'avons envoyé
à vous le plus beau tableau du monde au
plus près du monde au sens de la beauté
de l'âme aujourd'hui
[Musique]
classement en dernier Nicolas Pernikoff
en dernier Castaldi merci en
Bénaïm
Kenny ensuite
et tout est dépeuplé
[Applaudissements]
qui répond pas à mes sms alors c'est un
sms
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous le savez
le temps
alors à l'instant de mon
ami.
qui est à jamais notre jules à tous et
le roi des petits
je suis sûr que la vérité quand même par
le
passé derrière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Google
personne pour me dire que je venais de
passer 2 jours sous les UV personne pour
me dire que je suis c'est le
gouvernement
2 jours sans soleil puis je creuse dans
mon cœur et d'espoir mon étoile qui
brille et j'ai remis mon armure
[Applaudissements]
quel est le meilleur c'est gentil ça me
fait plaisir mais il y a encore deux
magnifiques
ça va vous sinon on va très bien
[Rires]
endurant insubmersible animal de mode et
de dancefloor et puis soudainement
souffrant
un SMS à la 2 jours une éternité enfin
tu nous reviens the show must go on
welcome back
monter les jardinerie tu es très fort
à mes 3 langues maternelle
Thomas Goran
j'embrasse mon père James pulling
mon père
[Applaudissements]
dis non pardon
j'ai sorti ma plus belle plume et c'est
un poème en alexandrin
[Musique]
on se retrouve tous les trois toi moi et
le jacuzzi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dernier ça ne change pas Nicolas
Pernikoff
c'est-à-dire
[Rires]
antépénultième
percevoir mon émotion
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ensuite,
ensuite viens Guillaume
ensuite Kelly
[Musique]
jolie ils ont un très beau cadeau pour
gagner
[Rires]
weekend
en troisième position
Bernard Montiel
j'ai compris
[Rires]
tu sais
c'est quoi
ça
c'est surtout pour me faire sucer par
vous
[Rires]
tu vas t'éclater
le grand gagnant
je veux des poèmes
celui qui va passer un weekend ou c'est
parti en weekend avec mon amoureux mon
amoureuse
[Applaudissements]
avec qui voulait partir avec vous
non je pars avec Fatou elle sera trop
contente surtout si c'est vous qui est
au frais en weekend elle va me dire oh
là là c'est bon weekend dans ma vie
[Rires]